prime minister
dear christianis secretary general
diane's
ministers generals admirals
excellencies distinguished guests
i am really sorry we cannot all meet in
riga today
i keep many good memories from my visits
to latvia
as a german defense minister and i have
always believed
that security in the baltics is a
european
matter that concerns all europeans from
riga to rome
the riga conference has become a key
annual appointment
for transatlantic relations so
allow me to begin with a few words on
the transatlantic community
there is a shared transatlantic cradle
built on the four freedoms outlined
beautifully by president roosevelt
during world war
ii freedom of speech and worship
freedom from need and from fear
and this is who we are this is why we
feel
we are part of a transatlantic community
beyond politics and administrations a
community of people
a community of shared
and that was of course still true
regardless of the outcome of the us
elections last week but like most of the
world
i watched the elections intently
and i want to again warmly congratulate
president-elect joe biden
and vice president-elect kamala harris
i very much appreciate the kind words
they have found
both for europe we can assume that the
tone in the white house will change
and we will again be able to address
daily concerns and issues but
what we should not expect is to turn
back time or to go back to a world of
before the united states have
changed europe has changed
the world has changed and yes wounds can
be healed
but some shifts and priorities and
perceptions on both
sides of the atlantic run much deeper
than one politician
or one administration
of course our alliance is based on
shared values and history
it is based on a common belief in
working together
to build a stronger more peaceful and
more prosperous world
and these goals will always endure
but i believe it is now time for new
transatlantic agenda
fit for today's world and i believe
it is europe who should take the
initiative
we look very much forward to work with
the new administration on areas
that can strengthen our bilateral and
multilateral partnerships
and this should cover everything from
security
to sustainability from tech regulation
to trade from leveling the global
economic playing field
to strengthening global institutions
these are not only eu us issues
and our alliance is not just about us
but a close and trustful cooperation
between the us and europe
must be the backbone of a new global
alliance
it is about working with emerging powers
and like-minded partners around the
globe
from africa to latin america from
australia to democratic asia and far
beyond
it is about working in our common
interest
for the common good europe has a lot to
contribute to such a close
and flourishing partnership its economic
strength
its leadership in areas such as data
protection
and green technologies or its
diverse international relations and
diplomatic networks
but europe also needs to develop more
strength in some areas
to improve the transatlantic cooperation
and certainly
in the area of security for years
i have been a strong advocate of
strengthening the european pillar
of nato the alliance had to change
and to modernize nato has done
an excellent job in fulfilling its
mission of collective defense
new countries have joined the threats we
face have changed
and the burden sharing within the
alliance is also changing
europe started to step up we are now
investing together
as europeans in capabilities that we
currently lack
and this will strengthen nato as a whole
we have invested in military mobility
within europe
we have invested in our cyber
capabilities and in our response to
hybrid threats
and europe must continue to make good
use of the new tools that we created in
recent years
such as the permanent structured
cooperation on defense
and the wide cooperation established
between the european union
and nato the eu member states
which are also members of nato are well
aware of their remaining
shortcomings and must continue to work
to overcome them
security is a common good
but the past year has also shown us once
again
how fragile our world is a virus smaller
than a grain of dust
has managed to put international
cooperation to a new test
and in the face of the crisis some have
chosen to isolate
other have tried to use a difficult
situation to strike
geopolitical gains
europe has chosen to lend a helping hand
from the very outset we organized the
global response to coronavirus
we convened more than 40 countries
to collectively raise over 16 billion
euros
for tests treatments and for research
towards a vaccine
we helped set up covax
a global initiative to create the
largest portfolio
of vaccine candidates in the world
and we brought together 186
countries but also ngos business leaders
and philanthropists and together
we are securing millions of doses
of future vaccines for low-income
countries
no country can achieve this alone but
together we can
and we want to invite everyone to join
us
we need to pool our expertise share our
resources
and coordinate our approach to tests and
treatment
to vaccines and vaccinations and here
too
i see great potential for europe and the
united states of america
to work more closely together
common positions and joint action are
also
urgently needed in other areas
i would like to focus in particular on
the situation in our eastern
neighborhood
the people of belarus are asking for
democracy
tensions have risen once again in
nagorno-karabakh
and the poisoning of alexey navalny
represents yet another violation of
international law
by russia's leadership
in these months the european union has
taken
clear positions on all these
developments
and i believe that decisive action must
follow now so let me present
two ideas for a renewed engagement by
the european union beyond
our eastern borders
first our european global human rights
sanction regime finally it will
allow us to target those responsible
for human rights violation worldwide no
matter where they occur
we have proposed a number of sanctions
from freezing assets
to travel restrictions so to maximize
the
impact of our measures
and second i would like a
more strategic approach to our economic
cooperation
since 2014 the european union has
mobilized over 15 billion euros
to accompany ukraine's stabilization
and thanks to our support ukraine is
today
a much stronger country
and this is what we have to offer to
countries
who decide to embark on a substantive
reform process
and this is what we could offer to a
democratic belarus
the people of belarus are asking for
free and fair elections
they see people going to the polls in
these very days in ukraine in georgia in
moldova
and they ask for the same right
democracy in belarus this is their goal
and this is what we want to support
and this is why the european heads of
state and government have asked the
european commission
to prepare a plan of economic support
for democratic belarus the european
union stands ready to mobilize
all its economic means to support and
accompany
democratic change europe's
economic influence is immense
it is up to us to make a more strategic
use of our economic clout
it is up to us to take clearer positions
and to enforce them with stronger
actions
i will keep working for an assertive and
courageous europe
and i know you are on our side
thank you